laurent saint-honoré bonjour bonjour
monsieur caruge et bonjour aux auditeurs
de matinée que la première candidats
pour les élections municipales à saint
joseph avec l'équipe
choisissons d'avancer ensemble mais vous
êtes aussi laurent saint-honoré le
président du golden d'aion football
alors est ce que le fait d'être
président de cette association sportive
de ce club vous a motivé à être candidat
en vous disant peut-être qu'avec cette
situation ben vous êtes suffisamment
populaire pour relever le challenge
alors c'est vrai que depuis mon plus
jeune âge j'ai toujours été dans les
associations pas seulement aux golden
eyes and puisque très tôt j'ai été au
case de chapelles mon quartier ensuite
je j'étais au racing club de saint
joseph
autre club de foot de la commune où je
suis j'ai fait mes armes je suis passé
par tous les postes effectivement
jusqu'à la présidence et après il ya eu
le bol et n'aime qu'on ne présente plus
avec les résultats qu'on a obtenus
alors alors justement ce succès du club
golden lanyon peut-il rejaillir sur le
candidat laurent saint-honoré s'est fait
le calcul que vous avez fait c'est à
dire le cern sans que ce soit ils
s'étaient jurassique et enfin c'est à
dire que la gestion d'un club de foot
effectivement ça génère beaucoup
d'éléments qui ressemble à la gestion
d'une ville
vous avez de la finance vous avez de
l'éducation et de la santé
c'est du sport vous avez toutes sortes
de deux paramètres à prendre en charge
en c'est vrai que ça a permis que
beaucoup de personnes me connaissent
beaucoup de personnes qui me rencontrent
dans la revue qui me disent président
que je ne connais pas les me connaissent
par la télé par les médias et par tout
ça mais ce n'est pas seulement ça c'est
surtout dû aussi je crois que c'était un
peu dans les tuyaux
c'est un peu dans mes adn on m'a
toujours sollicité par rapport aux
succès collectifs parce que bien sûr on
ne réussit pas seule dans la vie c'est
un travail d'ensemble et le groupe et ça
fait pas mal d'années que j'ai été
sollicité mais je n'étais pas encore
prêt aujourd'hui à 49 ans je pense que
c'est le bon moment
alors dites moi alors enceinte honoré en
tant que dirigeant du golden nahyane
football vous avez eu très certainement
à travailler avec le maire actuel qui ne
se présente pas pour tenter un nouveau
mandat mais comment cela s'est il passé
et à l'aune de cette expérience
justement avec le maire sortant comment
appréciez vous la décision finale
d'athanase jeanne rose bah c'est à dire
que bon je respecte sa décision il faut
dire qu'il sort de 19 années de
mandature
c'est vrai que depuis plus d'un an et
demi nous tous on savait qu'il y avait
une forte probabilité qui ne se
représente pas et celui ci peut être
bien pour ça aussi tout le monde me dit
à beaucoup de candidats à saint joseph
donc je pense que c'est pour ça aussi
c'est une commune quand même de 16 mille
habitants avec quand même un fort
potentiel en développement donc c'est un
peu normal qui étant le candidat et je
respecte mais je m'en veux faire mais
comment alors vous respecter son choix
mais comment vous vous situez par
rapport à la majorité municipale est ce
qu'on peut considérer que vous êtes de
cette mouvance la queue de ce camp là
entre guillemets ou est-ce que vous vous
inscrivez en opposition est ce que vous
critiquez c'est à deux le bilan de la
mandature qui s'achève non
personnellement je me présente dans une
élection 2020 2026 sincèrement je leur
laisse le choix de faire leur bilan
j'ai toujours travaillé en tant que
président de club avec tous les maires
en place avec je n'ai pas fait de
politique dans le club je dirais non
j'ai toujours respecté j'ai toujours
invité toutes les personnes de la mairie
que ce soit conseiller général
conseiller régional quand nous faisons
les peaux de banane et donc je suis
resté dans cette position estimez vous
que la municipalité joséphine soient
laissées dans un bon état de
fonctionnement général est aussi dans
une bonne situation budgétaire à votre
connaissance alors c'est à dire que je
reviens parce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure je les laisse faire leur bilan
c'est vrai que nous pas entendu d'un
bilan de quelque chose c'est vrai que
nous avons des propositions à faire par
rapport à un constat c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment la situation de la ville un peu
difficile notamment sur la
redynamisation du bourg
les gem répond même parler d'un élément
qui est qui me touche ça concerne la
l'insertion des jeunes en difficulté
dans le beau on n'en parle pas
mais sans aider ces jeunes en difficulté
ça va être difficile de rodman vous dit
qu'on n'en parle pas mais c'est vrai que
saint joseph a eu cette petite
réputation maintenant enfin cette
réputation va pas donner le qualificatif
d'être un des lieux les plus chauds
peut-être où il ya un peu plus de 2 je
dirais de désoeuvrement de la part de la
jeunesse et tout ce que ça peut
entraîner quoi on sert de nocif trafics
de toutes sortes violence délinquance
entre jeunes ou moins jeunes d'ailleurs
parce qu'il s'agit pas non plus de
stigmatiser forcément là la jeunesse
mais c'est vrai que saint joseph a eu
pas eu cette réputation là depuis
quelques temps c'est par la seule
commune c'est pas la seule commune
mais c'est bien ce que je vous dis ce
sont ces jeunes se sont dénoués fin ce
sont nos frères ce sont nos cousins ce
sont les enfants de nos amis donc
personnellement moi mes hauts de
saint-joseph en mars 2020 ja proposerait
de faire un audit de sécurité et de et
d'insertion c'est a dit que je prendrais
un cabinet d'insertion et de sécurité
pour pouvoir appuyer le travail du
service d'insertion parce qu'il ya quand
même un service d'installation à saint
joseph
mais il faut les aider et dans cette
mission bertrand car oui vous savez
chaque année quand on va dans les villes
il ya un événement qui se passe au mois
de juillet qui est très intéressant on
évite les bacheliers par exemple on les
récompense tout le monde est content
juillet août les vacances parce qu'est
ce qui se passe au mois de septembre on
a plus d'informations sur ces jeunes ni
sur ceux qui ont échoué aux examens et
c'est là que le décrochage se fait dans
cette mission de sécurité moi ce que je
propose avec ce cabinet d'audit
c'est qu'à partir de septembre tous les
mois septembre octobre novembre décembre
nous fassions ce qu'on appellerait un
déjeuner de la chance en invitant ces
jeunes et on est un profil sur eux et en
leur faisant une proposition avec tous
les autres acteurs que sont le pôle
emploi le sm a et de façon à pouvoir les
aider à sortir de cette difficulté
merci laurent saint-honoré s'est passé
très vite
l'entretien est déjà terminée merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci à
rodrigues calix pour la réalisation
technique